Добрий день, дорогі
дев'ятикласники та дев'ятикласниці!
Моє ім'я Ігор Хворостяний і я радий
вітати вас на уроці української мови!
Тема нашого заняття сьогодні:
"Складне речення. Види складних речень.
Розділові знаки в словосполучникових
складних реченнях".
Допомагати мені на цьому занятті буде
відома американська
виконавиця Біллі Айліш,
яка увійшла до Книги рекордів
Гіннеса як наймолодша музична
виконавиця, що тримається в
провідних світових музичних чартах.
Почнемо з початку.
Складне речення - це яке?
Яке ж із речень можна вважати складним,
а яке, на противагу йому, є простим?
Відповідь є елементарною:
складним називають
речення, у якому є дві і
більше граматичних основи.
Як ви можете бачити з зображення,
Біллі досить скептично
ставиться до такого визначення,
оскільки "граматична
основа" говорить їй небагато.
Спробуємо розібратися.
Погляньмо на приклади наведені на дошці:
Ставало холодніше, і на душі
робилося сумно, непривітно.
Осінь за вікном, і журавлі
ладнаються летіти у вирій.
Це речення є складним, оскільки містить:
перше речення - дві граматичні основи.
Перша граматична
основа - ставало холодніше;
друга граматична основа -
робилося сумно, непривітно.
В другому прикладі:
Осінь за вікном, і журавлі
ладнаються летіти у вирій.
Маємо підмет осінь -
перша граматична основа;
і журавлі ладнаються летіти
- друга граматична основа.
Отже, ці речення є складними.
Не плутати граматичну основу з
однорідними підметами чи присудками.
І не плутати граматичну основу з
Погляньмо на речення:
Найменший шерхіт, луск гіллячки,
шум пташиного крила, цокання копит -
все резонувалось тут надзвичайно
лунко, чисто, повноголосо.
В цьому реченні ми
маємо аж п'ять підметів,
тим не менш, лише одну граматичну основу.
Для того, щоб не плутатися з
визначенням граматичних основ,
будьте уважними з тим: чи це дія,
яку виконує підмет, стосується присудка,
і чи присудок відповідає всім тим
підметам, які наведені у реченні.
Іншими словами, і шерхіт,
і луск, і шум, і цокання
- все це резонувалось
тут надзвичайно лунко...
Порівняймо з першим реченням:
граматична основа
"ставало холодніше" ніяк не
пов'язана з граматичною
основою "робилося сумно".
Ще один приклад.
Чорні, голі дерева стояли
в садку, настовбурчившись
замерзлими гілочками, і, наче
мертві, не ворушилися од вітру.
Речення просте, але вже не з однорідними
підметами, а з однорідними присудками.
Оскільки, і стояли, і не ворушилися -
стосуються одного підмета - дерева.
І дерева стояли, і дерева не ворушилися.
Отже, це речення просте
з однорідними присудками.
Ще приклад.
Перед ним відслонилося море,
і було воно фосфорично осяяне,
мерехне, повне німого руху й
трепету. Це речення є складним.
Знайдемо граматичні основи.
Море відслонилося -
перша граматична основа.
Воно було - друга граматична основа.
Просто було, а було
осяяне, мерехне, повне...,
ми маємо тут приклад складеного
іменного присудка повне руху і трепету.
Узагальнімо.
Речення, в якому дві і більше
граматичних основ, є складним.
Речення з однією граматичною
основою, чи з кількома підметами,
чи з кількома присудками, але
граматична основа одна - є простим.
Які є види складного речення?
Є три основні види складних речень.
Перший - речення безсполучникове.
Другий тип - сполучникове.
Третій - з різними видами зв'язку.
Що означає сполучникове?
Це може бути складносурядне
або складнопідрядне речення.
Розглянемо ці приклади далі.
Безсполучникове речення
- це речення, частини якого
з'єднані без сполучників,
за допомогою інтонації.
Наприклад:
Сонце світить, пташки співають.
Зазвичай, коли малюємо
схему такого речення,
ми використовуємо квадратні дужки,
аби вказати на те, що частини
рівноправні і не з'єднані сполучниками.
Біллі вважає, що це елементарно просто.
Справді, шукаємо граматичні основи.
Якщо на межі граматичних
основ немає ніяких сполучників,
таке речення безсполучникове,
слово говорить саме за себе.
Сполучникове складне речення.
В сполучниковому складному реченні
граматичні основи будуть
з'єднані за допомогою
сполучників або
сурядності, або підрядності.
Найтиповішими сполучниками
сурядності є сполучники:
і; й; та; та й; також; ні -
ні; ані - ані; не тільки.., а й;
не лише.., а й; як.., так і; або;
чи; або - або; чи - чи; то - то;,
не то - не то; чи то - чи то; хоч -
хоч;, а; але; проте;, зате; однак...
Частини складнопідрядного
речення з'єднані
сполучниками підрядності
або сполучними словами:
бо; через те що; тому що;
завдяки тому що... та інші.
Біллі, як ви бачите, тут доволі скептична.
Вона сумнівається, що всі ці сполучники
можна запам'ятати і тримати в пам'яті.
Я спробую полегшити вам
життя і порадити ось таке:
найкраще сурядні сполучники
запам'ятати за словом-реченням-приказкою:
”ЧИАБОТАІ — коми ковтає!
Ви, можливо, знайомі з цими сполучниками
ще коли вивчали однорідні члени речення,
оскільки саме цими сполучниками
з'єднуються однорідні члени речення.
Ще раз: ”ЧИАБОТАІ — коми ковтає!”
З цього речення витягаємо сполучники:
чи, або, та, і... і однотипні з ними.
А також, не зайвим буде
додати сюди: проте, зате, однак.
Запам'ятати це досить легко.
Таким чином, у вас в пам'яті поступово
вироблятиметься модель сурядності
і ви легко зможете асоціювати схожі
з цими сполучниками більш складні.
Підрядні, відповідно,
інші, оскільки, є тільки
два типи сполучників в
цьому конкретному випадку.
Таким чином, Біллі теж
підтверджує, що так справді
трохи легше і краще
запам'ятати всі ці речі.
Детальніше про складносурядне речення.
Складносурядним називається
речення, частини якого рівноправні.
І ось вам ще одна опція.
Якщо раптом вам не вдалося запам'ятати
спрощений варіант сполучників сурядності
”ЧИАБОТАІ — коми ковтає! +
Проте, зате, однак”, є другий спосіб.
Частини складносурядного
речення рівноправні, незалежні, а це
означає, що від однієї частини до
іншої не можна поставити питання.
Приклад: Сонце світить, співають пташки.
Умовно, говоримо про те, що частини,
граматичні основи, які входять
до складу цього складного речення
Сонце світить, співають пташки...
Є відносно рівноправними і
незалежними стосовно одна одної.
Схема дуже нагадує схему
безсполучникового складного речення,
єдине, що додається
сполучник в схему так само.
Рухаємося далі.
Складнопідрядне речення.
Частини складнопідрядного
речення залежні, вони не рівноправні,
вони з'єднані підрядними
сполучниками та сполучними словами.
Приклад:
Пташки співають, коли світить сонце.
Що означає, що ці частини не рівноправні?
Це те, що від головної
частини пташки співають,
можна поставити питання
до підрядної світить сонце.
Пташки співають коли? Коли світить сонце.
Таким чином, головна частина
та, від якої ставлять питання,
другорядна - до якої ставлять питання.
Легко зорієнтуватися за таким правилом:
підрядна частина завжди
починається з засобу зв'язку.
На схемі підрядна частина позначається
круглою дужкою, головна - квадратною.
Ще кілька прикладів.
Коли світить сонце, співають пташки.
Сенс цього речення не змінився,
я лише переставив місцями.
На перше місце у мене вийшла підрядна
частина і на другому місці головна.
Отже, ми фіксуємо - підрядна
частина стосовно головної
може перебувати як в
позиції перед нею, так, і після.
І третій приклад.
Пташки, коли світить сонце, співають.
Як бачимо, підрядна частина тут
вмонтовується в головну,
входить в її середину.
Головна частина пташки співають,
вона розірвана підрядною
частиною коли світить сонце.
На схемі це також відповідно відображено.
Ще раз нагадаю пораду,
яку я вже озвучив — підрядну частину
досить легко знайти за засобом зв'язку.
Тобто, ви спочатку знаходите засіб
зв'язку, і ви бачите, що це приклад,
коли підрядна частина
стоїть після головної частини.
В цьому випадку, наш засіб
зв'язку коли, тоді підрядна
частина стоїть перед
головною і в середині головної.
Як я вже сказав, є ще третій варіант,
коли ми поєднуємо, комбінуємо
сполучниковий і безсполучниковий зв'язок,
або сурядний-підрядний з відповідним з
відповідним безсполучниковим зв'язком.
Це всього лише чотири випадки.
Випадок перший.
Сполучниковий сурядний і підрядний.
На душі радісно - перша
частина, сполучник сурядності
і, друга частина — хочеться співати.
Як бачимо з речення ЧИАБОТАІ —
Коми ковтає, і це сполучник сурядності.
Отже, перша і друга частини
поєднані сурядним зв'язком.
І хочеться співати коли?
Коли світить сонце, це підрядна частина.
Таким чином, ми маємо
комбінацію сурядного і
підрядного речення в складі
великого, нашого складного.
Сполучниковий сурядний і безсполучниковий.
На душі радісно, хочеться співати,
і пташки витьохкують щосили.
Перша і друга частини
з'єднані інтонаційно,
тобто безсполучниковий зв'язок,
друга і третя частини
з'єднані сурядним зв'язком,
на це вказує сполучник і,
і частини рівноправні.
Отже, речення зі сполучниковим
підрядним і безсполучниковим зв'язком.
На душі радісно, хочеться співати,
коли пташки витьохкують щосили.
Перша і друга частини
безсполучниковий зв'язок,
третя і четверта — підрядний,
на це вказує сполучне слово коли.
Сполучниковий сурядний і
підрядний та безсполучниковий.
На душі радісно,
хочеться співати, і природа
здається неймовірною, коли
пташки витьохкують щосили.
Перша і друга частини
безсполучниковий зв'язок;
друга і третя - сурядний,
сполучник і; третя і четверта
підрядний зв'язок, на це
вказує сполучне слово коли.
Підрядний зв'язок, на це
вказує сполучне слово коли.
Поговорімо тепер про розділові знаки
в складносурядних і
складнопідрядних реченнях.
Найперше, що потрібно
запам'ятати, це кома.
Найчастіше між частинами
як складносурядного, так і
складнопідрядного речення
ставлять саме цей розділовий знак.
Цвітуть картоплі, і мак по них цвіте.
Будь-ласка, не плутайте
однорідні члени речення,
з'єднані сполучником і
на зразок мама і тато,
там не потрібна кома перед
і, зі складним реченням.
Граматична основа
картоплі цвітуть, мак цвіте...
Між частинами складносурядного речення
перед сполучником ми маємо поставити кому.
Моєму серцю снишся ти,
як морю сняться урагани.
Тут перед підрядною частиною як морю
сняться урагани, також ставимо кому.
Це найтиповіший,
найрозповсюдженіший розділовий знак
для сполучникових складних речень.
Що стосується складнопідрядних,
там взагалі крім крапки з комою інший
розділовий знак трапляється вкрай рідко.
Поговоримо тепер про відсутність коми.
Ці правила стосуватимуться
лише складносурядних речень.
Якщо частини складного речення
з'єднані одиничним сполучником
і мають спільне слово, найчастіше
цим спільним є обставина,
як у нашому прикладі:
Вдосвіта знов загули на морозі
сосни і закричали півні на горищах.
Про що йдеться?
Ми маємо дві граматичні основи -
сосни загули і півні закричали.
Але я не ставлю кому
перед і, оскільки обидві
ці частини мають спільну
обставину вдосвіта.
Сосни загули вдосвіта, півні
закричали також вдосвіта.
Якщо дві граматичні основи
стосуються одного і того самого слова,
найчастіше обставини, це
також можуть бути частки,
вставні слова, то тоді ми не ставимо кому
між частинами складносурядного речення.
Інший приклад, спільними
можуть бути не лише окремі слова,
а й окремі цілі речення
як фрагменти складного.
Погляньте, будь-ласка з Шевченка.
Поніс Гонта дітей своїх, щоб ніхто
не бачив, де він синів
поховає і як Гонта плаче.
Ніхто не бачив Чого? Де він синів поховає.
Ніхто не бачив - це спільна
частина - чого? Як Гонта плаче.
Таким чином, я не ставлю
кому перед сполучником і.
Також, відсутність коми можлива
між частинами складного речення,
з'єднаними одиничним сполучником, якщо
речення питальне, спонукальне або окличне.
Аналізуйте одразу фінал речення...
Знак оклику, я не ставлю кому перед і.
Фінал речення — знак
питання, я не ставлю кому
перед сполучником і між
частинами складного речення.
Крапка з комою - це не такий
поширений розділовий знак, як кома,
тим не менш, він може траплятися,
в тому числі і під час диктантів.
Між ускладненими або далекими
одна від одної за змістом частинами.
Про що йдеться?
Якщо ми маємо таке велитееееенське речення
і ми, по суті, можемо розподілити
це речення на два смислових блоки.
Один блок і інший.
І кожен з цих блоків значно ускладнений
і обтяжений своїми розділовими знаками.
Річка широка та глибока,
а вода синя та чиста; -
це перший смисловий блок... і
котиться вона, виблискуючи та шумуючи.
В першому смисловому блоці
ми маємо однорідні означення...
Широка та глибока, а вода синя та чиста.
В другому — виблискуючи та
шумуючи, відокремлено обставину,
виражену дієприслівниковим зворотом.
Тобто, і так розділових
знаків в самих частинах, що
входять до складу складного
речення, досить багато.
Аби ці смислові блоки якось розділити один
від одного, ми і ставимо крапку з комою.
Тире (—).
Тире ми ставимо між частинами
складносурядного речення,
якщо друга частина виражає висновок чи
наслідок того, про що
йдеться в першій частині.
Настане час — і піде все в архів.
Коли їм сумно — хай вони сумують.
Тобто, смислові відношення між
частинами складносурядного речення
тут перебувають у зв'язку
висновковості чи наслідковості.
Аналізуйте це, вставляючи,
наприклад, слова
ЯКЩО настане час, ТО піде все в архів.
Дуже легко запам'ятати,
що перед ТО ми ставимо тире.
І нарешті.
Коли йдеться про збіг двох сполучників.
Це один з найскладніших
випадків пунктуації
складного сполучникового речення.
Соломія міркувала, що коли брати у ліву
руку, плавні мусять швидко скінчитися...
Я маю два сполучники поряд
— що і коли, в одному випадку.
І друге речення.
Мама каже, що коли уві сні
літається, значить, росте він, росте!
Що і коли в цьому реченні
також збігаються, проте
в першому варіанті ми
ставимо кому, а в другому ні.
Як знати, коли ставити і не ставити?
Дуже просто!
Спробуйте частину, яка починається
з другого сполучника, просто викинути.
Якщо вона викидається і
сенс речення не втрачається,
ставте сміливо кому між
цими двома сполучниками.
Соломія міркувала, що плавні
мусять швидко скінчитися...
Таку процедуру в другому реченні
ми зробити просто не можемо.
Мама каже, що значить росте він, росте.
Речення втрачає свою
структурну і смислову єдність.
Якщо ця частинка не викидається,
кому не ставимо. Все просто.
Кому також ми не будемо ставити,
якщо перший сполучник протиставний.
Наприклад, ТА (в значенні АЛЕ),
А, АЛЕ, ЗАТЕ, ПРОТЕ, ОДНАК.
Мій біль бринить, зате коли сміюся,
то сміх мій рветься джерелом на волю.
Зате коли — два сполучники,
відповідно, я не ставлю між ними кому,
тому що перший сполучник якраз є ось
цим протиставним — ТА, ЗАТЕ, ОДНАК.
Біллі пропонує нам
своєрідну гру або провокацію:
“А поясніть но розділові
знаки в реченнях із моїх пісень”.
Спробуємо зробити це.
Перша пісня
“Я більше не хочу бути тобою” має
таку назву в перекладі українською.
Якби сльози можна було зібрати, то їх би
вистачило, щоб заповнити
басейни для моделей.
Отже, пояснюємо розділові знаки.
Ми маємо першу підрядну
частину, на це вказує ЯКБИ.
Відповідно, я маю
відокремити підрядну частину.
Я говорю про те, що підрядні речення
найчастіше відокремлюються комами.
То їх би вистачило... а далі
іде третя підрядна частина -
щоб заповнити басейни для моделей.
Тобто, я так само ставлю кому в
підрядному реченні перед ЩОБ.
Другий приклад.
З пісні “Наслідувачка”. Я нікому не
належу, але всі знають, як мене звуть.
Перша граматична основа я не належу,
друга — всі знають, і звуть
— третя граматична основа.
Зв'язок між першою і другою частиною
сурядний, досить легко, оскільки,
перед АЛЕ і А ми завжди ставимо кому,
хіба, окрім випадку, коли з цих
сполучників починається речення.
А друга і третя частини
з'єднані підрядним зв'язком...
Всі знають ЩО? - сполучне
слово підрядності — як мене звуть.
Третій приклад.
“Схрестивши пальці” називається пісня.
Коли світ зануриться в тишу й дні
будуть тягнутися довго, лишимося лише ми.
Це цікавий випадок, оскільки,
ми маємо дві підрядні частини:
світ зануриться в тишу і
другий — дні будуть тягнутися,
але обидві ці підрядні частини, за
логікою, я мав би відокремити їх комою,
але я того не роблю,
оскільки обидві ці частини
стосуються однієї головної
— лишимося лише ми.
Лишимося лише ми, коли
світ зануриться в тишу.
дні будуть тягнутися довго.
Таким чином, я не ставлю кому перед Й.
Пропоную вам звернути увагу
на тестові завдання з цієї теми.
Біллі Айліш складати
ЗНО навряд чи доведеться,
а ось вам, дорогі мої дев'ятикласники і
дев'ятикласниці, рано
чи пізно, це вас не мине.
Пропоную проаналізувати цей тест, а
потім надсилати ваші варіанти відповідей.
Складносурядне речення
утвориться, якщо серед варіантів
продовження речення “Зранку
ми почали непокоїтися...” обрати:
А - проте день був чудовим.
Б - бо кожен з нас думав
про можливі перешкоди.
В - так що настрій
зіпсувався на цілий день.
Г - й обговорювати можливі небезпеки.
Д - передчуваючи серйозні проблеми.
Правильна відповідь на цей тест
А - проте день був чудовим.
Ми маємо граматичну
основу день був чудовим.
І ця граматична основа
приєднується до граматичної основи
ми почали непокоїтися за допомогою
сполучника сурядності ПРОТЕ.
Другий тест
Кому НЕ потрібно ставити між
частинами складносурядного речення
(розділові знаки пропущено)
А - Від пісні журливої дуб сколихнувся
і лелеки здригнулись вві сні.
Б - Теплий день розхлюпує блакить
і ластівки купаються в промінні.
В - Свинцем набрякли
сині хмари і сонце зникло.
Г - Я у думках до мами пригорнулась
і стало гарно і затишно мені.
Д - Сонячний день млосно дихав
запашним теплом свіжої ріллі і
дзвінкоголосі жайворонки
дружним хором славили весну.
Правильна відповідь - варіант А.
Третій тест
Тире потрібно поставити між
частинами складносурядного речення
А - Реве Дніпро й лани
широкополі медами пахнуть.
Б - Хвилина ще і схід розпише
в сліпучі барви небосхил.
В - Десь у хлібах кричав
перепел і туман стелився од річки.
Г - На хвилину раптом
стихли голоси і спинилися тіні.
Д - Сині роси зблискували на
травах і сонце купалось на левадах.
Правильна відповідь на це завдання — Б.
Лунає дзвоник і це значить,
що наше заняття закінчено.
Я щиро дякую вам за участь,
зичу вам якнайбільше перемог.
А наступного разу будемо говорити
з вами про види підрядних речень.